open up the developer API guide for
settings if you want to follow along if
you've pondered it carefully and you've
decided you really want this to be a
setting this is what you do next
Android provides a way to display a
hierarchy of preferences including
headers such as the ones shown here the
value of the preference is called the
preference summary and that's seen here
it looks almost like the subtitle text
the preference also provides UI to allow
users to modify that setting you just
need to supply the strings but you don't
have to implement the UI like the
spinner here common preference types are
the checkbox preference with preference
edit text preference we can see some
examples in the Settings app under
developer options here's a bunch of
preferences this is an example of a
checkbox preference this is an example
of a list preference where you have
different radio button options here once
the user changes the setting it gets
saved in the default share preferences
file this stores a bunch of key value
pairs of primitive data an example
integer preference could be how many
days of email history should be saved
locally on the device you could have a
string stored and shared preferences for
what the currently selected account in
the device is then at any time you can
fetch the value of the shared
preferences as long as you pass in the
name of the key that you want you can
also use shared preferences outside the
context of settings as well this
information is located in the developer
API guide for storage options which is
also linked below